j'ai vraiment réglé je suis au lit à 20h
20h30 tous les soirs ça ressemble à quoi
une journée type une journée type c'est
lever 6h30 6h40 petit déj et tout
ensuite entraînement l'entraînement
commence à 10h en général mais moi je
commence à 8h par travail individuel sur
le terrain un peu et je peux venir à 6h
il y aura des coachs ici c'est j'ai même
pas besoin de prévenir personne il y
aura toujours TR qu coach qui seront là
pour m'entraîner tout entraînement 10h
collectif ça joue ça joue
ensuite d'autre travail muscu cardio
tout ça maison repas sieste pas tous les
jours mais moi dès que je peux je
reviens à l'entraînement dans
l'après-midi mais mais souvent iless ils
essaient de m'empêcher de revenir tu
vois pourquoi
bah parce que ils veulent faire
attention ils veulent prendre soin de
moi c'est normal dès que je peux je
reviens quoi jusqu'à ce qu'on me dise
Victor tu tu as interdiction de revenir
formellement euh ce weekend